my one more thing is very family  friendly as in my own family it's about  the Rollins police department in Rawlins  Wyoming right there on i-80 take a look  at this my mom and aunt are from Rawlins  Wyoming and this is David Greninger and  he has a villa named Bella and that is  his canine dog she's a certified drug  dog and a beloved member of the Rawlins  force him away from me I also have a  yellow lab his name is nacho nacho dog  that is how H Oh chi-su and uncle Rodney  still live in Rawlins Wyoming and in  fact they you know they own memorylanes  the bowling alley but it's for sale so  if you're in the market for a bowling  alley  how Q is for sale nacho dog my favorite  Dana's corny joke is jalapeno jalapeno  business cheese yeah well that's a  throwback to it although we favor corny  joke